[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un smartphone
qui était présenté il ya quelques temps
en septembre 2018
à l'ifa c'est le motorola one alors
motorola c'est une marque que j'ai eu
juste des smartphones motorola mais l'a
longtemps plutôt je dirais pour ma part
avant l'avant les smartphones n'étaient
pas sûrs d'ailleurs j'ai le peuple les
smartphones motorola et j'ai eu des
téléphones portables motorola faudra qu
après c'est vrai que c'est plutôt les
sur l'iphone apple mais je suis jamais
allé chez motorola et donc agi très
content de pouvoir tester un smartphone
de motorola avait déjà pris en main
d'autres smartphones mais en tests n'ont
donc ça pour moi c'est une première je
suis content mais ils ont tous un
smartphone qui est assez intéressant
parce que qu'il va situé dans le milieu
de gamme en dessous des 300 euros donc
la question à se poser aujourd'hui c'est
est-ce que motorola réussi son pari dans
cette typologie de produits est ce que
ce motorola one est un bon produit oui
non est-ce qu'ils écoulent oui non voilà
tout ça tout ça tout ça dans ce que je
propose c'est on ouvre on teste on
regarde comment il marche on regarde ce
qu'il est bien à la fin on fera un
débrief et puis vous surtout aux
commentaires vous glisse que vous en
pensez voilà la boîte j'ai déjà sorti le
produit 1 il est là je vais vous le
montrer dans quelques instants
on va commencer par la botte j'aime bien
le design est assez sympa les couleurs
sont son coût y ait eu un bon boulot de
fait bon paquet jimmy pas non plus hyper
révolutionnaire mais ça fonctionne bien
quand vous l'ouvrez à l'intérieur vous
tombez normalement directement sur le
smartphone avec ce petit col en europe
sur le dessus qui donne un peu la
couleur et qui vous disent qu'on pourra
retrouver à l'intérieur
petit bout de plastique vous ouvrez
ensuite on a notre petit petite pique
pour ouvrir le tiroir de cartes sim
on retrouve de la doc pour vous
expliquer quoi et où et quoi il sert à
quoi ici et ça donc ça c'est cool
voilà plus la partie garanti à
l'intérieur on retrouve ensuite ici un
casque prise jack donc ça c'est cool
quai du jack de l'usb à usb type c'est
parce qu'il se recharge en usb type ça
c'est cool et on a un blog de recharge
rapide 15 watts mais ça je vous en
parlais après un peu plus tard quand on
parlera d'autonomie voilà pour la boîte
c'est cool c'est beau c'est réussi voilà
maintenant le smartphone est ce qu'il ya
c'est rigolo là dessus c'est qu'il
arrive comme ça avec sa coque qui est
directement posée dessus il ya beaucoup
de constructeurs qui vous mettre des
coqs dans le packaging mais tu ne passes
pas dessus glace est plutôt pas mal
alors qu'on va faire c'est que on va
alors moi le smartphone franchement je
trouve pas mal je trouve assez bien
réussi je trouve pas l'eau la prise en
main est franchement bien c'est pas
révolutionnaire on n'est pas sur un truc
qu'on n'a pas vu on n'est pas sur un
truc complètement ouf mais néanmoins il
fait le job et c'est ce qu'on lui
demande on retrouve ici le logo motorola
qui est positionnée au niveau du capteur
d'empreintes digitales double module
photo ici avec flash led au milieu on en
parlera tout à l'heure vous avez ici
android one parce qu'il tourne sur
android one bon la certification
européenne bouton pour l'allumer bouton
de volume haut parleur mono qui situent
juste là usb type c'est ça ça ne sert à
rien c'est une jolie petite billie
pofalla déco vous avez si votre tiroir
double nanosims plus car microsd ou est
monté jusqu'à 256 go de stockage sur le
dessus vous retrouvez votre prise jack
bon ici un petit micro voilà c'est assez
simple assez sobre mais ça fonctionne
bien je vous dis en prise en main c'est
cool on trouve très facilement capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui va venir up
sur l'appareil photo qui va venir le
déverrouiller extrêmement rapidement
ça marche ça c'est cool alors on voit
sur la face avant
vous avez ici une grande encoches bon on
est sur un smartphone à moins de 300
euros en terme de design on n'a pas non
plus trop trop trop lui en demander le
manteau en bas et assez impressionnant
est vous retrouvez la marque motorola
après dans cette gamme de prix
fondamentalement ça me choque pas du
tout on a un corning gorilla glass tu
fais pas que sup face et robuste il
n'est pas révolutionnaire le design
n'est pas complètement ouf c'est des
choses qui sont déjà vus il ya un gros
manteau en bas bon néanmoins le patron
trop lui en demander une fois de plus on
reste dans une gamme de prix en dessous
de 300 euros même aujourd'hui bien en
dessous des 300 euros donc ça c'est
plutôt cool
maintenant on va regarder un petit peu
ce qui se passe au niveau de l'avant au
niveau de l'écran on n'est pas du tout
en full hd là dessus c'est peut-être un
petit peu en 2.2 reproche au niveau de
cet écran on a un écran 1520 par 720
pixels
on est à 2 187 pixels par pouce il est
le diagonal de 5,9 pouces format 19/9
c'est une dalle ipc du lcd et l'écran
occupe 80% de la face avant pour
visionner du contenu sur youtube ça va
par contre vos gains
la partie avec l'encoche n'est pas du
tout du tout utilisé ça c'est mon wifi g
c'est un choix bon ça fonctionne ça
vidalies troquereau paie aussi dans
l'image pour la vidéo en intérieur ça va
si vous allez mettre en extérieur face
au soleil vous allez manquer un petit
peu de luminosité
ça peut aussi être un petit point de 1
petit point de reproche alors là tout de
suite on est au mois de décembre quand
je tourne j'ai pas vous l'envoyer en
extérieur pour voir ça en poussant un
peu plus loin pas forcément apparaître
l'écran mais proche du but
médias vous avez un haut parleur mono
qui situe la lodyans et pas officines il
ya un peu de son néanmoins ce que je
vais approcher
c'est qu'il commence un petit pull à
saturer ici on a une prise jack on va en
profiter
[Musique]
c'est honnête c'est honnête mais c'est
pas hyper hyper fort d'un autre côté
d'un autre côté je vous le dis souvent
le but ce n'est pas de se rendre
complètement sourd ans en écoutant de la
musique au casque
je pense que lorsque vous allez dans des
lieux un petit peu bruyant type métro
t-il train vous allez manquer de
puissance un peu là dessus
après ce qu'il faut vraiment avec ce
smartphone là ça va être un casque à
réduction de bruit vous avez du
bluetooth 4.2 on n'a pas du bluetooth
5.0 ça peut aussi être un petit mot un
point de regrets notamment par rapport à
un casque bluetooth
bon il faut aussi raison garder
maintenant on est sur un smartphone qui
coûtent moins de 300 euros donc je sais
je sais je me répète beaucoup mais c'est
très important de replacer le smartphone
dans son contexte c'est à dire dans sa
gamme de prix pour le comparer à des
smartphones comparables on joue à des
jeux tu pas soit ni trop franchement ça
va très bien vous n'avez pas profiter de
jeux complètement honte là dessus vous
n'avez pas beaucoup beaucoup de
puissance vous avez un snapdragon 625 à
danser jusqu'à 2 giga hertz
je vous parle en même temps que je joue
c'est hyper dur de se concentrer en gpu
tesla dreno 506 4 gigas de ram 64 giga
de stockage vous montez votre faux cage
jusqu'à ou olala s'est crashé magal
pouvaient voter votre ce cas jusqu'à 256
j'y viens gaza la carte microsd
l'autonomie franchement ça va on a une
batterie 3000 milles et inférieur quand
j'ai une façon la fiche technique je me
suis dit 3000 milles et en perd heures
aujourd'hui peuple un petit peu un petit
peu limite limite alors on va pas avoir
un jour et demi deux jours d'autonomie
c'est vraiment pas le but de ce
smartphone là dessus vous allez plutôt
avoir une belle journée d'autonomie sans
aucun problème alors après dépend
toujours votre utilisation si vous
bourre idée si vous y aller à fond la
ville autonomie vous n'allez pas l'avoir
par contre si vous faites des jeux un
petit asphalte ni trop de temps en temps
elle n'est pas forcément un truc trop
trop gourmand c'est un pas trop trop le
l'adn de ce smartphone des réseaux
sociaux de l'imec du téléphone la
journée vous l'avez sans aucun première
après ce qui est cool c'est que vous
avez aussi le boccia que 15 watts au la
recharge rapide
en effet le manque de tomber en usb t-il
sait alors ce qui est cool avec ça c'est
que vous les mettez vingt minutes de
recharge vous repartez alors il nous
annonce huit heures de l'utilisation
toujours un peu compliqué parce que ça
dépend effectivement de votre
utilisation il faut savoir que pour
recharger complètement il vous faut
quand même une heure et demie et je fais
tout tomber cette catastrophe
il vous faut une heure et demie pour
recharger complètement voilà après je
trouve que l'autonomie là dessus c'est
vraiment un des points forts de ce
smartphone
qu'en est il maintenant en termes de
photos/vidéos autant des voix au niveau
du smartphone il ya pas mal d'options
qui sont vraiment cool pour optimiser
des photos pour les partage sur les
réseaux sociaux pour la vidéo vous avez
aussi de la stabilisation su ça aussi
c'est franchement cool vous pouvez
filmer onu hd jusqu'à 30 images par
seconde
ou alors en full hd en 60 images par
seconde très personnellement je vous
recommande d'aller sur du full hd
ressentent images par seconde sera
parfaitement bien à faire et même en
vidéo la caméra c'est l'fun
au niveau photo vidéo vous avez
l'arrière un double capteur 13
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.0
et un deuxième capteur de 2 mégapixels
ouverture de f 2.4 lui il va travailler
pour le mode portrait le petit flash led
au milieu il ya là une caméra de 8
mégapixels ouverture de f 2.2 il à vous
pouvez filmer en full hd à 30 images par
seconde
d'un point de vue logiciel vous avez
plusieurs modes mode photo mode vidéo
là vous allez arriver sur le mode
portrait et là vous avez pas mal de
possibilités votre mode portrait qu'ils
retrouvent la filtres couleur cinéma
graff panorama ralentis accélérés
youtube light le rendu est pas
complètement dingue la voyeuse manque un
peu de précision est ce que c'est moi
qui ait bougé vont en tout et c'est pas
impossible là tout ce qui tourne à un
peu plus de précisions le rendu au
niveau des couleurs est correct un là
franchement la colorimétrie ça va je
trouve que c'est pas sûr saturé par
rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver à la
concurrence ce nouveau traitement
logiciel ça c'est franchement honnête là
j'ai fait le point sur les feuilles au
centre voyagez pas le point le point et
les faits un peu plus par derrière par
ici là c'est un peu plus dur à centrer
alors est ce que ça vient une fois de
plus de moi qui ait bougé sur l'image
c'est pas impossible non plus trouve que
voilà c'est une petite difficulté pour
faire le point là dessus ça c'était un
petit peu un léger point de regret sur
ce sur ce smartphone aboyer typiquement
je me suis posé sur la feuille là ça
fonctionne très bien
est-ce que la surface était plus grande
tout de suite ça l'a reconnu plus
facilement c'est complètement possible
là les couleurs sont assez belle il ya
du détail c'est bien je pousse et c'est
sain c'est un rendu qui cali
là j'ai pris la photo avec la caméra de
celle fille ça me lis énormément le
visage là j'ai eu un grain de peau qui
est lissé dechellis et je vous raconte
même pas comment ça c'est notre photo
que j'ai prise avec la caméra arrière
c'est assez bien fait le rendu est
correct ça dépend je pense effectivement
de vous si vous bougez si vous bougez
pas pourtant vous avez une stabilisation
dessus la soif et la faim là on va se
mettre sur le mode qui s'appelle le mode
filtres couleur ça c'est assez marrant
le mode filtres couleur parce que je
suis sélectionné une couleur qui sera la
couleur hop je la gardais ça me supprime
tout leur est envoyé la saga que le
rouge
et ça marche bien mais du rouge derrière
de maupeou au crayon il ya des roues sur
la lampe son but son doigt et qui
éclaira ça me connaît du rouge
vous sélectionnez ce que vous voulez hop
genre le marron derrière ça me reconnais
du mas rouma méthane jones et ça vous
donne des images qui sont assez marrante
la sauvegarde et le orange et sur la
plante là j'ai gardé que le verre là les
oranje et a disparu là que le rouge
la voyait son et chaussures que le
orange et dont on ne connaît un peu les
teintes qui sont déclinées et là
typiquement c'est la faute aux normales
hélas la photo est le filtre donc c'est
assez marrant voyez ça c'est rigolo
le mode portrait fonctionne pas trop mal
le flou est vraiment bien fait bien
respecté il ya un bon détourage bon on
n'est pas sur le stand dragonne le plus
puissant là dessus néanmoins ça fait ça
fait le job de ce point de vue là et
même lorsque je vais continuer si fier
la selle voyez ça ne détourne bien le
doigt alors là ici là un peu plus
souffert sur la partie intérieure
bon c'est deux points de détail
franchement ici c'est pareil entre les
doigts et a eu un peu de mal de tout et
ça c'est normal on n'est pas sur un
socle est hyper hyper récent c'est pas
le plus performant de tous mais je
trouve qu'en tout cas s'en sort plutôt
pas mal quand on sort un android world
s'est fondé sur un orero 8 points alors
l'idée c'est qu'effectivement vous avez
des mises à jour garantie pendant trois
ans à partir de la date de lancement
la date de lancement c'était le 13
septembre 2018 donc jusqu'en 2021 vous
êtes tranquille vous aurez des mises à
jour de sécurité
donc ça c'est aussi plutôt cool vous
profitez d'une expérience quasiment
android stockent si ce n'est que vous
avez en plus des petites choses motorola
en plus des gestes je vous montre ça
c'est rigolo
par exemple pour l'allumer la torche
voulu mettait deux gestes tranchants up
s'allume la torche de gestes tranchants
salle et un pour allumer l'appareil
photo est aussi de faire de rotation du
poignet hop vous arrivez sur l'appareil
photo
vous avez aussi du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé enfin la massue smartphone
dans l'absolu je trouve quand même
plutôt pas mal en tarif a été présenté
il était à 299 euros
je le trouvais un petit peu cher pour ce
tarif là je trouve que par rapport à la
concurrence est allé s'offrir la vous
trouve à 50 euros de moins
229 euros et là franchement je trouve
qu'il est vraiment bien positionné il
est dans dans le tarif en tout cas
auquel il devrait se vendre le mieux
sauf que motorola lassus a sorti un
smartphone qui est franchement honnête
dans le milieu de gamme dans l'entrée du
milieu de gamme à 229 euros
c'est un bon produit on peut y aller
après ce que je vais regretter un petit
peu là dessus c'est le défaut au niveau
de la qualité audio
c'est pas non plus complètement dingue
bon l'encoche on aime on n'aime pas la
prise en main est franchement bien
l'appareil photo des petites options qui
sont assez marrante
ce qui est très bien là dessus c'est
l'autonomie et je trouve que pour un
produit motorola a en usb tissés avec de
la recharge rapide à 229 euros pour moi
c'est un produit qui est franchement
honnête je sais pas vous comment vous le
vous trouvez ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous l'avez acheté ce produit est
ce que vous avez déjà des smartphone de
motorola
alors il ya des prix qui sont beaucoup
plus haut de gamme chez motorola je
trouve qu'il a vraiment un des atouts il
défend il a quelques points négatifs
elle aussi des points positifs
après ça dépendra vous de l'affinité que
vous avez déjà avec la marque de ce que
vous recherchez
si vous voulez un smartphone robuste
avec une bonne autonomie que vous n'êtes
pas forcément un très très grand fan de
photos de qualité à partager sur les
réseaux sociaux
si vous cherchez pas non plus une
expérience multimédia complètement folle
de moulins smartphone correct robuste
résistant avec une bonne autonomie pour
moi le motorola one fera franchement la
faire et à 229 euros
il ya rien à redire dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
vous invite à rester connectés parce
qu'on va parler beaucoup d'autres
smartphones n'a pas mal de tests à faire
alors pas forcément dans cette gamme de
prix là j'ai reçu l'autre jour je sais
pas si vous l'avez vu on a le réseau fon
de alors là c'est on est sur du très
haut de gamme
on est sur un smartphone de gaming avec
des performances de ouf c'est pas la
même chose
on a aussi d'autres trucs dont on a
testé on va tester la une caméra quatre
cas de logitech on a reçu aussi ça c'est
cool je l'avais parler ya longtemps
celle heidegger boucle de lenovo donc on
va reparler de solutions de paie ça fait
pas mal de choses donc vous allez taper
une chose déjà c'est à vous abonner pour
suivre toute la cub et puis pour
comparer les smartphones et tout savoir
sur les smartphones à suivre ma playlist
vous allez voir il ya tous les
smartphones du moment
quasiment tous à peu près il était de 2
3 kg châtelet mais je pense que
franchement on fait le tour
vous pouvez regarder que ça nous fera un
avis sur tous les smartphones regarder
ce qui se paie ce qui est bien ce qui va
bien voilà un soyez sages vous embrasse
et à très bientôt
ciao